where in the world like on this planet
do you have time to like Garden cook
prep do all this stuff like you're so
into I am too but I don't have a ton of
time like how do you find the time and
do your kids eat your food they well the
harder you work on a meal the less
likely they are to eat it yeah have you
ever noticed that when you really sweat
and you've really tried something new
and that's when they're just like I'm
not hungry thanks which is the code for
I don't like it but I'm not really
hungry I'm okay I had apples and you
just feel like yeah but if you throw
something together then you know that's
literally every parent you just
described at meal time yeah like I like
especially my three-year-old son I'm
like seriously like it doesn't matter
what I put I could put apples in front
of me he loves it and then the next day
he's like I hate apples right right
right I mean the the trick is to care
less don't wear caring on your face yeah
and don't try you're not sure I don't
care if you whatever I mean I made
homemade pasta it's fine it took me
three hours yeah it's like eat it or not
it's fine it doesn't even matter yeah
okay sure yeah yeah everything's fine
yeah so yes they do sometimes now that
they're getting older they're starting
to eat eat more yeah so where did Once
Upon A Farm come from because we
actually have in our household that's no
lie they actually love it so glad when
my kids were babies I I went to the
store I was a working mom the first
thing that I opened it looks like cat
food baby food in a grocery store it's
been sitting on the shelf forever and
the kids should sit there like longer
than a Twinkie and it's been
everything's been cooked out of it just
doesn't even make sense so I knew there
had to be a new and a better and a
different way and I found Cassandra
Curtis and Ari Ross and they were doing
um this amazing different way of making
baby food just using technology and cold
pressing it yeah so that you don't cook
the nutrients out it has all the fiber
and the flavor and the colors and the
vibrancy and all the vitamins a lot of
people don't know what that is but yeah
it keeps all of that still yeah so what
it does is it puts it's like put it you
you put it under the pressure of nine
oceans basically the weight of nine
oceans is what they say
anyway but you were raised on a farm
right I wasn't raised on a farm my mom
was raised on oh in Oklahoma that's in
Oklahoma and it is now um it's our
family farm and now it's growing produce
for Once Upon a farm that is so good
right dude congratulations
it's all much fun I know and especially
when you're a parent you start it's like
you don't care about yourself but for
some reason when you start procreating
you're like wait what's going in them
well you know what's funny is that you
go you talk to friends and they say my
dog is eating human grade food I mean my
dog you can eat the food that my dog
eats it's in a cooler at the grocery
store and then meanwhile we go and buy
baby food and it's mush and that's what
we're used to it doesn't make sense it's
like not with no color that's like the
worst for them like when it's all just
like beige right right right right
they're like no green and I'm like okay
cool and then I hide it in a sippy cup
so it's great weekend we offer all the
recipes for anything that we do so you
can because we always have a great hero
ingredient like turmeric because that's
cool or it really is
all kinds of different things so we
always have something great in there for
brain development or whatever and so we
offer the recipes if you can make it
great if you can't we've got you covered
I love it yeah I do I think it's so
important
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]